talk to me in terms of just the current
state of bitcoin right obviously we've
seen everything from regulatory
pressures to some of the energy flood um
but it feels like bitcoin is doing
exactly what it was designed to do um it
just kind of produces block after block
after block is that your evaluation um
how do you think about where we are
right now
yeah i mean bitcoin is uh kind of a
power run for itself and and people will
say glib things like bitcoin doesn't
care but i guess you know to some extent
it doesn't it just keeps producing
blocks and
one of the beauties of the kind of
decentralization or survivability of
bitcoin versus previous
much more centralized electronic cash
systems is that
you know individuals and companies can
leave and join the network at will and
you know even whole countries can uh
restrict use of bitcoin and bitcoin
carries on and you know in certain
countries it
depends on the culture but you've seen
cases where
a country
like
will ban bitcoin and the usage will
actually go up or move to you know
decentralized platforms for hc trade and
things like that so that's kind of
interesting because there's a
there's one form of bootstrap for
bitcoin
which is that
you know you could do all word of mouth
you know if there's enough bitcoin
acceptance and deployment that you could
ask around for a friend of a friend and
financially to like in-person otc so i
think bitcoin is probably at that point
already and the
you know the emerging market adoption is
actually
accelerating
faster for for payments and sort of
hands-on use
than the west which is you know which is
great and obviously they have more
more limited
uh
payment options compared to what we have
in the west with you know more stable
currencies debit cards bank accounts and
start so they have a reason to adopt
perhaps similar to the way they kind of
leap frogged
um
fix the line telephony and skip straight
to mobile phones right so they have a
problem to solve and so the
street is figuring out how to solve it
in bitcoin
yeah i mean in the month of july 1.2
million new entities on the bitcoin
blockchain fastest growth uh ever
recorded in a month so pretty incredible
what do you think the biggest hurdle for
bitcoin is over the next five years
um
i mean it'd be interesting how it
develops of course it's
it's it's impressive how the game theory
you know so
it's evolved over time as bigger players
have come in
there have been some
kind of policy skirmishes but basically
the market has prevailed and
so i think that's one of the very
interesting eliminating aspects of the
you know so-called block size war right
which is to my mind what that you know
without regard to what people
thought or preferred but ultimately the
market prevailed and that that says the
bitcoin is you know it proved its its
jobs in being in a political money that
ultimately
you know interest groups don't stand
much chance because the market will tend
to sort of around it prevail
so that's great but it may get
interesting if you know you have uh
sovereign bitcoin positions mining
so i think a certain amount of
decentralization
and
individuals
and entities holding them product and
private keys helps if there if there's
too much
kind of etf-like use that could pose a
policy risk because the
etf managers may feel they have a
fiduciary responsibility to do something
that the users
wouldn't want to do i think ultimately
the market prevails anyway but
that could be
uh trophy shall we say
there's a lot of conversation right now
online about
bitcoin maximalism do you consider
yourself a bitcoin maximalist or are
there other things that you're
interested in or open to how do you
think about
maximalism and then everything else
yeah i mean to me it's really um
a kind of neutral
uh bitcoin monetary maximalist so
you know the i'm pretty interested in
any kinds of innovation uh you know the
bitcoin sector and
uh
blue sky academic research and a number
of chains have
brought to market some pretty
interesting innovations over the last
five years
and
so there's you know obviously innovation
is great and change can copy and learn
from each other and where it gets
kind of
debatable is is the kind of switching
cost of chains so john feffer has a
pretty interesting
uh paper on this where
he makes the argument that basically it
doesn't make a lot of sense to
pre-buy and hold utility tokens where
the utility token is like a coin that
you use to pay for
smart contract execution or storage or
something in a chain
because technology gets cheaper and you
know if a chain gets expensive people
will switch chain and then you'll be
left holding the wrong uh utility tokens
so
it's a bit like
you know early enthusiasm about the
internet and somebody proposed
pre-buying you know megabytes of
bandwidth or something in the 90s and of
course you know the cost of bandwidth
dropped
multiple orders of magnitude so i think
the just in time argument means that
there's definitely utility value in the
chain but there may not be
kind of defensible sticky
value after you take into account
switching costs and as i say i'm
expecting that to play out in the market
you know mid to long term
what do you think the price of bitcoin
hits by the end of the year you think
about price at all
is there any sort of framework you use
to evaluate uh these kind of cyclical
bull and bear markets
uh yeah i mean i'm a bit of a
trader on the side and was doing some
arbitrage and different types of trading
before starting block streams so
i was a day trader back in the
late 90s as well you know stocks and
stuff so
kind of interested in trading dabbling
and trying out the different bitcoin
products you know perpetual futures and
options and things
so
um
but i think even before the stock to
flow valuation model
which is it's an interesting observation
we'll see if it holds
i think the the comparison i liked was
the
sort of
um competitor to physical gold because
in many ways bitcoin is a better
physical gold and so you know you can
infer a kind of valuation from how many
coins there are
current price of gold and you know let's
say that that value gets divided up and
you come out into the hundreds of
thousands uh like maybe half a million
even
on that basis alone so end of year um
i mean
the the options prices for you know 100k
are
showing that that is the markets that
came that's quite possible um so
i'm uh i'm curious to see if that comes
would you bet on it are you are you
buying options
uh well i mean actually i uh looked at
the ledger x
options
and concluded that they were under price
so i should buy some
basically most of them i mean basically
because you can compare them to the
kind of not risk-free but a somewhat
risk uh incurring
bitcoin yield so if you if you collect
interest on bitcoin
and you can see that the option gives
you less return than collecting interest
on bitcoin that says you should buy you
should buy the option because it's it's
cheap compared to that
um
so
yeah i might take a pun on that as well
so because people's normal intuition is
well i'll sell some options
because i get money now
and
you know if if that price is here well
it's like i put a limit order in and
they got triggered and i was
philosophically happy to sell that price
but now if you look at the price
underneath and you think those things
are
under price then logically you should
buy some
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]